do you remember Cowboy Camp I loved it
oh yeah oh I loved it I loved it wait a
minute wait a second oh it's a surprise
oh a freaking surprise it's a surprise I
have no idea what's coming hi everyone
it's Linda o from Bad Girls your
executive producer I ended up having the
most wonderful time but let's face it
weren't we all really bad girls a number
of us were actually arrested um you Dre
also Drew I wanted you to know that I
spent all morning looking for the note
you left me at my Texas house um I've
had it on my refrigerator for 30 years
each and every one of you is um always
in my heart for sharing this crazy
wonderful experience with me bye am I
fir now oh my
gosh I I cannot believe this is
happening who I am is because of Linda
and you guys I I mean I was 17 I didn't
know where the hell I was going with my
life I mean I when I was on set like
Andy you were someone that like I had
literally been watching and was so in
love with like had idea such a hero to
me and Mary St I mean I was so obsessed
with every movie you were and you were
my style icon I would always talk about
how you would change yourself for each
character like the way you were in some
kind of wonderful versus like a and June
like all right and June so good
everything like you did I was I like I I
was so enamored with both of you and I
was being given a real chance like to be
in this film with you and it was a huge
opportunity for me because I had been
sort of gone and you know had lost a lot
of the opportunities by you know sort of
you're a baby heaven sakes but I'm sure
you put a lot of pressure on yourself
listen I love mid midlife crisis at 13
it's awesome I highly recommend it it
gets it out of the way and I was able to
come back and have a second chance at
life and work was my life because I met
friends like when people say work you
know and life should be
compartmentalized to me I feel the
opposite I think you can make friends
and family I think you can find true joy
and happiness you can find empowerment
and that film is the one that sent me on
my way for the rest of my life with
Direction and purpose that I did not
have before I came together with you
guys it's true it's so
incredible oh oh my
God and look at you now yeah I know it's
great isn't it this is so fun to be able
to turn on the TV and watch you thank
you this is like a very bizarre Surreal
Life moment